good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is live in the moment over to
you Conor McGregor I don't like to think
too far ahead so you haven't told oh no
I don't like her link identified I had
people set like goals long distance
goals and she that's too much for me I
already feel like I'm living it and then
I just carry on the old I know carrying
on day by day already living the final
goal the goal of being the world
champion I already carry myself like I'm
not world champ and I already speak like
I'm a world champion and that's it I
just carry on day by day so I'll take
her as a corpse a lot and like I said
you're awesome ask me about the future
I'll let you I'll let you know a little
bit closer and I mean as far all I can
see right now is the gold that's all I
can see I don't put too much faith in
five-year or ten-year plans it's one of
the most common questions I get asked
when I do interviews what are you gonna
do in five years where do you see your
YouTube channel being in five years or
ten years I have no idea I don't even
all still be doing YouTube in five years
or ten years I think what's really
important is that you have a mission of
something you're trying to accomplish a
general direction that you want to go
and some big goal that you're trying to
reach but then not be so attached to how
you're going to go out and accomplish it
and so I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs Conor McGregor wanted to
win the World Championship great I want
to help a billion entrepreneurs how I
get there doesn't matter right I've
gotta do something that I enjoy that I
have fun doing that I feel is having a
big impact but the specifics doesn't
matter
and so I know my long term of where I'm
going and then I know what I'm working
on right now you know at the end of the
year I want to try to have a million
subscribers every you know week I'm
creating content making videos for you
guys and when make you know kind of
minor changes along the way and
introduce new things and new ideas but
am I still going to be on YouTube in
five years I don't know
what am I going to be doing in five
years to ten years I'm going to be doing
something awesome to help reach a
billion entrepreneurs that's what I'm
going to be doing that's what motivates
me and so I think it's great to have
plans right planning is great it's not
that you don't want to have any plans
you don't want to have any goals you
want to just wake up and see what
happens because most people don't just
wake up and do something amazing you
know having some kind of plan having
some kind of structure helps you on the
days when you're not really motivated
this is important whenever I feel like
what I'm doing is out of whack doesn't
feel right anymore I'm yearning for
something out you know you get that
little frustration bubbling up that I
want to add something else in and it
doesn't my current schedule doesn't
allow for whenever I feel like that then
I have to rejigged my schedule I've got
to figure out okay what no longer serves
me and what am i yearning for how can I
put that in and I can't plan for that
that's a challenge you don't know what
kind of person going to be in five years
or ten years or what's going to interest
you with the new things that have come
out you know ten years ago YouTube
wasn't even a big thing if it was I want
to help the billion entrepreneurs I
might do that by getting on MySpace
which was all the rage ten years ago
then who cares if I'm the number one
myspace ER right now it's not going to
help me achieve my goal to help a
billion entrepreneurs and so I think
having a specific target can really be
helpful in terms of you accomplishing
that target but it doesn't mean that
that's going to actually help you with
your long-term goals and so I'd be
stubborn about the big thing you trying
to accomplish but be flexible in the how
the other thing I really have a hard
time and maybe this is for you guys too
is whenever I set a goal that might be
multi years out like I initially
immediately already want to think of how
to accomplish that right now I would
look at a five-year goal and say how do
I do it in five months how do I get that
happening fast or even just the idea of
something coming into my head of
something that I want to do one day I
start taking action on it just naturally
if I want to I wanted to build a house I
want to build a custom modern house from
scratch and again that'd be good to do
one day just having that thought in my
head boom within a year I had my own
custom house being built it just starts
to happen and I think getting used to
taking action on your ideas is also
really super important those plans you
have for five or ten years it don't have
to be five or ten years if you took
action started doing stuff on it right
now you can make that happen
in five months or less maybe five weeks
or five days for some of you if you
actually started taking action on it and
so again I think it's important to be
stubborn about what you want to
accomplish because you're going to need
it you're going to need to be stubborn
you're going to need to do it to face
criticism and face your fears and get up
every day into action but be flexible on
the how and I would strongly encourage
you if you have a five year goal or ten
year goal for yourself raise your
standards and start asking yourself how
do I hit that in five months so the
question of a today is I'm curious what
is your 5 or 10-year goal that now you
want to condense down into five months
leave it down in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out and if you
leave a comment within the first few
hours of this video going live you have
a chance to win one of our two daily
prizes
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Michael Peterson Michael thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book
your one word I hope you enjoyed the
read and it really really really means a
lot to me
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso
for this recipe me go
I've had seasons where I've had the
worst surgeries ever and I've been
through I had seven surgeries you know
and and that alone you know you actually
sell time and time again how do you
bounce back from that yeah yeah but I've
always used it as you know taking that
time to strengthen myself I never knew I
was going to place everything is you
know who could have ever thought that
you don't you don't see and you come to
leave you don't say you know what I'm
gonna play 17 years and you don't even
think of it that way you just say I take
a get by you and that's what I try to
tell kids don't move to make sure too
fast just like don't go to tomorrow too
fat deal with today deal right now
you know we've been a lock runner we are
pregnant and I'm like listen put this
all down because these moments will go
to fire and when they go on they go on
you know so before you look up you and 2
3 5 7 10 12 if you make it that long no
but there's no something's though you
know just like you spoke about early
most of these young babies never see
five years never see seven years never
Levantine your career you know so you
try to prepare them to understand what
the moment actually feels like and
that's why I think honestly why Mike
realized so long because I always lived
in the moment like it nothing else
mattered to me and I was selfish at
times because even for was my family
nothing else mattered when he came to
bat when he came to that I was bowed in
it's a it's a heck of a blessing to be
here now I'm walking I'm healthy you see
but don't make it an impact absolutely
hey absolutely so you know I just tell
people I don't know how long whoever's
gonna play but I will say enjoy every
moment
don't don't rush to guys you know let
your years take care of years but go
year by year go day by day hour by hour
minute by minute a head full of dreams
the tour's going on now you just got off
the South American life yeah I mean when
the crowds the show does it ever how do
you keep it fresh because it's not your
first rodeo it's your thousands ten
thousands I mean even doing it well
here's how I keep it fresh Bruce
Springsteen apparently I don't know if
it really does or not used to say to the
rest of the East Street Band
this could be someone's first showing it
could be someone's last show so let's
treat it like that so I have that
inspiration and then some other things
in my life that just make me but every
time before we go on stage I really
think about like who showed up how much
they've been through to get there Wow
and also for us at the moment we're just
soand we took a break from touring on
the last album we did it called ghost
story so we're so except we're so
excited to be there and we know that
nothing lasts forever so I think that
we're just really more than ever living
in the moment and and trying to
appreciate the fact that some people
except for us showing some people you
know no it's actually your perspective
that that's not a meteorite you like and
I worked for that perspective yeah we
definitely went through a period about
ten years ago of feeling like what are
we doing you know questioning everything
and not really able to take in the joy
of it that must have been hard
it won't work it was I mean everything's
in perspective but for us as a band it
was a bit hard like what you know but
but slowly just you keep going and you
find great people who come in and help
you out and teach you things and and I
think the more that you the more that
you let in it's very easy right now with
social media to letting anything
negative you know whatever you do
someone is going to slag it off online
well you're not on social media at all
personnel we are as a planet I don't
really personally - I'm not that good at
selfies okay that's an honest answer um
so so so so I made a decision right well
you know if you'd taken the bad stuff so
I'm going to really taking the good
stuff and appreciate who these people
have shown up and they want to sing our
songs together and that's great I'm into
it you know I can't ever know I brush
should ever get sold that's the thing it
never gets old for anything about gigs
is there's so many factors to make a
great gig like I mean I've gone stage so
many times thinking that was awful for
whatever reason you know you're Salman
I'll come in it was out fun to say
that's the best thing I've ever seen you
go leave or then you'll be offstage and
think but your band has played great and
he's really but and they somehow come in
and say well I lost the bass for six
songs you know I really are the
lightning man I'll say yes on the lights
didn't work so you know I mean it's kind
of
I don't really don't really judge gigs
while I'm doing it I'm just in the
moment I'm singing the songs when I come
offstage I don't like talking about it